[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
allow us to present mr. and mrs. Josiah
Smith average Americans of a
half-century ago
younger than the average Americans of
today but then their chances of growing
to a ripe old age were clouded with many
threats
[Music]
the last 50 years the sky has been
cleared of many of yesterday's perils
and today the average American lives
longer but it's well recognized that
medical science while helping him live
longer
pretty fair on the whole but while
there's very little smallpox now there's
plenty of high blood pressure
atheria is rare now but the spreading
waist line is spreading and along with
it troubles of the heart kidneys and
blood vessels and other problems of a
constantly aging population but the
control of many of these conditions
early detection is important there for
recent years have seen increasing
interest in mass screening devices for
example diabetes detection drives using
blood sugar tests or urine sugar tests
have been tried in many communities the
idea is to screen apparently well people
not already under their doctor's care
objective tests are used those with
sugar findings above a specific standard
are referred to their physicians thus
many unsuspected cases have received
early attention from their doctors but
to avoid the duplication of effort in
screening one month for diabetes another
month for tuberculosis
and another force if allah s-- the
question has been asked why not combine
various screening tests instead of many
separate screening lines why not combine
them into one multiple screening
multiple screening makes use of a series
of technical tests each taking less than
three minutes
multiple screening does not involve
diagnosis
the idea is to sit from apparently well
people those who may have a latent
disease or an unrecognized disability
and to refer them to their physicians
wherever such a project is carried out
the local Medical Society will help
select the tests that are included a
multiple screening project can be done
on a small or a large scale to suit
community needs
for example if blood is to be taken for
a syphilis case finding project such
blood samples can also be examined for
diabetes and anaemia this is multiple
screening in one of its simplest forms
if it is decided to add x-ray the x-rays
can be read put tuberculosis for certain
heart abnormalities and even for lung
cancer if it is decided to use urine
sugar tests for diabetes rather than
blood sugar tests the urine can also be
examined for nephritis other tests that
can be added are height and weight
hearing and vision tests blood pressure
tests oral examinations and perhaps
electrocardiograms
new tests can be added as they are
developed the community can select
almost any combination of tests it
wishes in one rural program two tests
were used in an urban area four tests
were used in another urban area seven
tests were used this is a matter for a
local decision
each community can develop a multiple
screening project to suit its own needs
the personnel needed for multiple
screening includes some administrative
personnel laboratory personnel and the
personnel at the testing center or
centers an average testing center needs
a receptionist several technicians
several clerks and a supervisor these
can be arranged in any convenient order
such a testing center can screen in one
day several hundred mr. and mrs. Joe
Smith's mr. Smith arrives the tests
begin each test must be inexpensive to
use as specific as possible and quickly
done Joe Smith spends only about three
minutes on each test in the screening
line technicians do the testing at the
end of the line he is reminded that any
positive reports will be sent to his own
physician this saves the most highly
trained type of personnel the physician
for the later work of interpretation
diagnosis and treatment thus through
multiple screening economical and
effective mass case-finding may be
provided in any community from the
general population the tests screen out
those who appear to need medical
supervision these are referred to their
own physicians a few of them of course
may be found by their physicians to be
well the others will be diagnosed as ill
and treatment begun multiple screening
can channel to physicians people with
unsuspected serious diseases or minor
disabilities earlier not to stabilize if
not
actually to correct the condition many
late complications can be avoided
through early diagnosis and treatment
the private physician of today because
of the rising importance of the chronic
diseases is in a dilemma watching the
stream of humanity passing his door he
knows that in his community there are
unknown cases of tuberculosis of
diabetes of syphilis of glaucoma of
heart disease
he knows that many of them will not have
their own accord seek medical attention
until disease has won a firm foothold he
also knows that if he could find and
treat them at an early stage he could
help them what can the physician do
ethics forbid him to put up a sign to
warn or persuade them he cannot seek
them out of all out to them he must
stand aside and remain silent but
multiple screaming as a community
project can do what must be done to
combat the chronic diseases it can turn
some of the people the ones in need of
early attention back to their own
doctors door so the idea of multiple
screening is to use mass screening
devices on people in general people who
feel well to bring unsuspected cases to
their own physicians early enough to
prevent complications or crippling
illness early enough to protect their
health while they have it
[Music]